so my background is HCI CS from the
beginning and
saying over the years too many years on
various forms of new interaction
technologies and interaction techniques
and have deep interest in augmented
reality but as michael explained it's
sort of has like expanded over the years
i would also say that although i have
taught myself a lot of things i've also
been fortunate to have spent a lot of
time and various different research labs
across across the world the media lab
most recently columbia university where
i started my research k th where did my
PhD micra service or for internship UC
Santa Barbara for a short research day
and RISD where I did some teaching so
the projects today I will not like go
deep into where everything happened but
sort of just remember that it's like a
broad collection of places so sometimes
i like to ground the my research in you
know some slice or some snapshot from
popular culture and i think this is a
particularly good example it's a movie
from the early 60s called the man with
the x-ray ice so no one's seen it in
here no one you should see you so you
should see it out of this homework in
this seminar series but maybe that's the
first at last so essentially about this
doctor does start experimenting with eye
drops these eye drops that arm to see
beyond the visible spectrum basically
receiving x-ray vision so he can quickly
diagnose patients just by looking and
looking through them so it becomes like
very very popular super doctor and i
think what it what's interesting about
this besides that it's a fascinating
movie and sci-fi from the 60s is usually
great but what was interesting about
this is that it's kind of also
summarizes our constant drive to go
beyond limitations of our physical body
via you know seeing
what we can see interacting in ways that
we we biologically can't and like sense
and experience things and it happens
that Ivan Sutherland actually almost
around the same time so also early 60s
started developing this concept of the
ultimate display which was this very
very brutal headworn device actually by
my PhD advisor stephen finer he
encourages not to use the word head him
off the display was more headworn
display it's obviously a nice news but I
think this is actually qualifies as I
had mounted display so so essentially a
track mechanically tracked apparatus on
the head and these transparent displays
in front of the eyes that allow him to
both see the world and graphics that can
I create the illusion that it's
physically and registered with the real
environment so this is kind of like one
of the earliest examples of augmented
reality from the computer science point
of view and my sort of some examples
along my journey on this little
arbitrary axis of realism has been going
from more like virtual graphics and
pixels that are created with different
types of displays it's more situating
these pixels in the physical environment
and then finally in the last couple
years we've been working a lot with
Daniel light dinner and Sean former
who's coming here and Russia she looking
at how we can make these these pixels
more physical so here is just like a
snapshot of some of these projects this
is a stir transparent 3d display we're
as user Santa Barbara we're looking at a
material displays that allowed us to
create this place you can walk through
and see through Microsoft we looked at
bringing more digital capabilities to
physical objects so kind of classical
tangible user interfaces I've been doing
a lot of things with mobile devices as a
way to extend the capabilities of
ments tracking them displaying relevant
interactions on the on the high res
displays that they provide and like I
said most recently turning into shape
displays and being able to actually
exploit physical form and shape capture
to bring these capabilities to the
physical world so try to this was a very
brief like snap shut off all of this and
I'll go a little bit deeper into each of
those so actually so what I was coming
returning from Columbia back to Sweden
where at Columbia we did a lot of things
with heroin displays like very immersive
a are a lot of sensors on the body and
basically looking at the vision you know
what if we actually have this completely
unobtrusive way to sense and provide
visuals in a very immersive sense in the
future and it's like looking at it more
from a prototype standpoint and sort of
ignoring the current limitations of the
technologies but when I returned back to
Sweden I was interested in you know how
can we approximate or deliver a similar
experience by more pushing out the
technology in the environment and I
think this is what comes back to what
what Michael said about that this is
very related to you become because a lot
of these projects are more about soph
embedding embedding the interaction and
bending the graphics and all these
capabilities and sensing in the
environment not requiring the user to be
be instrumented so this one of my first
projects that were not based on Warren
technology was asked her and this was
collaboration with the Department of
Production Engineering at the kth so
they have been developing this
horizontal parallax only her graphic
optical element that allowed allow us a
way to do stir scopic autostereoscopic
graphics with full transparency so
typical typical stare displays distort
optically distort was behind them
and that's sort of provide prevents you
from being able to actually see the real
real environment behind and this was a
way to actually preserve as much as
possible of the optical quality of what
what you're seeing through so we were in
the Department of production engineering
so we had this very sexy apparatus a
lathe nothing that you would bring to
your lab like two-ton machine such a
control computer work piece a tool that
cuts into the spinning workpiece and you
have obviously an operator who is very
interested in what's what's going on
here so you have the processed data
that's generated by the computer
measuring forces temperature pressure
all these things and at the same time
what's happening in the real world so
this is kind of a classical method
reality scenario you have like this
skitzo vision information the real world
and sort of like an interface that does
not match what what you're interested in
so we were just had like this idea of
let's take the data situated in the in a
physical space and but let's do that in
a way that's easy to come in and out of
and does not require the operator to
sort of instrument himself a head like a
lot of setup costs so these are just
some screenshots from that visualization
but essentially what you're seeing here
all the red graphics is overlay so we're
looking through this holographic optical
element and there's like two projectors
that project like an individual views
when you in the right like a central
sweet spot where you get see that stereo
pair with each eye so what you see is
these force vectors that are measured in
real time from from the Machine and then
projected back at the right depth with
like with the 3d graphics so what we're
not seeing here is you know the location
and yeah sorta like the the 3d
perspective of these two the result than
the three components of the force
and I mean one obvious thing is like
here we're just mapping it to data that
would situating in the machine the
operator is focusing all the time at the
things that are like the most
interesting and get this additional data
channel but also you can think about
other ways that this allows you to see
through the the work piece if you're
cutting behind or inside the workpiece
you're not seeing the tool and this you
know could be a way to actually provide
that extra layer of of sort of x-ray
vision so what's happening at here at
the end of the video is you know the
graphics were all crazy a little bit
unsure what was happening and I had to
ask the the main guy who's like spending
all his time on this on this machine you
know what you know is it you know is the
software a share or something and he's
just here's through sound that the tool
actually broke and that was what
happened I think that's sort of like a
great example of how clear it is with
just this situated graphics I would
never have noticed something that would
have changed on that screen to the side
if I'm in the inner physical space of
the machine so just many different
arguments for why augmented reality is
great and in this case we try to do it
in a very lightweight fashion that did
not involve a lot of effort on the
operators for nopers your perspective so
later on we looks that you know what
could we do in terms of making this like
more more interactive so so brought the
display to to my lab I could not bring
the Teuton lathe with me so this was
more looking at the virtual graphics we
collaborated with the walls a museum
that had like these amazing scat 3d
scanned artifacts from the sunken
battleship and sweden's were looking at
verse ways that we could extend these
partial pieces with virtual graphics we
go to museum is
like there's just like some remnants of
of the sculpture but an artist has
completed I think you should go and look
and experience it's like the fool or the
partial thing and for that and flow
scenarios were interested in you know
how would you interact and how would you
control these interfaces we just threw
everything everything we had in the lab
at the times like a touch over the night
tracker from toby z come from 3 DV
systems one of the early depth cameras
and looked both that's you know how did
they work in there and it sort of medium
scenario but we're also looking at
medical data sets so collaborated for
many years with new resurgent who is
very interested in you know bringing in
3d data and and MRIs and cities into the
surgery room and being able to control
it in a sort of like non touch touch way
but I mean one of the main constraints
with especially the sastra system was
that you have like this physical barrier
of the glass you can never really you
can simulate touching things that are
outside but not inside or if you're
thinking about using this in a more
collaborative scenario that's always
that that physical barrier so the UC
Santa Barbara we looked at you know what
could we do if we had a different type
of display medium that was not it was
not physical it was not a physical
barrier and we used device called the
fog screen so essentially an array of
ultrasonic elements that convert
basically vaporized water and you get
like this mist that comes down
essentially dry the problem typically is
that this business will just like flow
everywhere and you just get like a mess
from all the turbulence so just like an
array of fans that laminate dismissed
and keep it reasonably stable I'll show
you like here in this video so basic get
a material projection screen that you
can track your interactions
in and on we can also walk through it
and talk through it and reach through it
so it's essentially allows you to bring
pixels in the physical space and I think
it's kind of interesting like imagine
this presentation not being constantly
you know these you know i'm down at this
display i have like all these these will
pay surfaces but what if i could have
like a sure the content in between us
and talk through it so this was at
siggraph attack in 2005 the previous was
like a game where you were capturing
falling animals and dragon in two
different sides this is a circus
pseudo-3d elastic modeler where such a
scan from one of one of my collaborators
and he was not too happy I was like
deforming him for like a week public but
here you see like that actually we can
exploit the properties of our water
disperses lights is primarily in four
directions we have different content on
the front and back although the screen
is transparent so it's not like a add
you know diffuse to glass or something
where you would see the same thing lead
through so just like here one more time
other other game so we're focusing out
so this is a demo cap system and they
have tiny LEDs so's ya in their house
you can't really see so this is the mist
so vaporized water
alright
to you know these are like fun
experiments and in display technology
and what we can do if we you know have
the ability to integrate graphics in in
a physical environment but sort of still
it it always makes me think about you
know what is the ultimate display so
Ivan Sutherland was very clear like this
is you know this would what it could
look like and this is what we should be
able to do and it should be able to
simulate all these things but I think
that I mean is there's no real real good
answer to it and I don't think there
needs to be and cook you know again like
referring to what Michael said about but
you become it's just like this room is
like filled with this place and it's
like even more displaced or probably in
people's pockets or upside down or in a
bag there's more displaced in this room
than people and it's kind of a kind of
interesting what's missing i think is
more about the context and the
connection between them and our
interactions and how we sort of deal
with transferring content and so on so
so focused a lot as well on a sort of
more hybrid user interfaces and looking
at you know how you could interact
across this place and how a small
display can complement a larger display
and vice versa and i think that you know
this this plenty of opportunities in for
that there's also this notion about the
physicality so even with that ultimate
display you lose unless you also
complemented with other types of
displays for a lot of other senses you
know what was the benefit of just having
virtual graphics and how does that
relate to our you know the many many
many many years of evolution where we've
developed like these amazing
capabilities and dexterity too many
plates physical objects and things so
some of that is you know is easily found
in in the literature around tangible
user interfaces and the ability to the
idea to bring in physical objects and
sort of augmenting them in various ways
rather than the other way around
so when i visit the microsoft we were
specifically this was on the guess the
table formerly known as microsoft
surface so we were we were looking at
you know what what if basically on the
assumption that most objects will have
an rfid tag and in the near future and
will be like a very unobtrusive way to
tag up things and know what's in a space
but it doesn't tell you much about where
things are you can essentially RF is
great for scanning but it's not good
it's not trivial to locate things so
we're doing this sort of also in the
spirit of hybrid hybrid user interfaces
and techniques running this basic
multi-modal approach of we're using
vision force best like detecting change
not that great for recognizing things so
we detect changes in the vision stream
and then we synchronize that which
changes that happening on the tape ball
in a sort of the RF space so we
synchronize RFID and computer vision and
through that sort of resolve ambiguities
yeah I are yeah but it only really
matter and the one of the points with
this paper was that we explicitly wanted
to avoid sort of even computer vision so
it was more actually more like I would
say more image processing and try to
simplify the algebra of understanding
what's happening from frame to frame
with as few assumptions as possible and
then using RF to give all the
identification just like basically
classifying pixels the pro version of
more like capacitively based displays
you don't necessarily have the
importance of visual light walk a camera
underneath or on top sure but I imagine
that you could replace the camera on
every something that would be even a
piezo I don't even know something that
wouldn't require that kind of
that kind of infrastructure underneath
it oh yeah I mean I having so this
there's many different approaches any
you can like the well I don't know what
it was called but the the most recent
few years ago Samsung version to serve
four hundred extra surface they just had
like optical sensors now I know in each
pixel yeah so each pixel was not only
displaying light but also sensing light
so they're just getting a blob would you
know would you be able to do exactly the
same thing but i also would see no
capacity the touch sensor if the object
is interfering somehow has some sort of
a metallic fingerprint it can also work
so there was actually a 3m display they
had like these nice large capacitive
touch displays and now they you can
actually get access to the whole
capacitive image so i did actually test
that and just like put like a badge with
the rfid tag inside of it then you need
to get like a very nice sort of
signature so it's absolutely here it's
definitely not relying on actually
having the camera we use the camera
extremely modestly and this this case
and that was sort of like the point of
it yeah yeah and i should say also like
feel free it's not only your professor
that has the privilege to ask questions
feel free to interrupt at any time if
you're wondering about anything I'm
trying to keep in this pretty pretty
high level so I'm not going into
technical details so that's us used we
should ask if you want something so
still like I mean in in in the surface
fusion work we were more working with so
like dead objects I mean they were they
had a head of shape and a form and
enough for dance which is kind of
amazing in terms of you know being able
to many playthings very accurately
without paying any
now I'm able to speak and move this
water bottle and I should know exactly
what I'm placing it and this is just
like how my my body has evolved over the
years but what if you know this could do
something more interesting so so that's
where we kind of shifted also into
looking at mobile devices cuz you know
tracking them on surfaces just as like
another layer of input and output and
interactions around that so the lights
and system was was this idea to track
and modified mobile phones I was a
little hack of using the flashlight on
these camera phones like feature phones
like no with the physical buttons yeah
so this was also relying on on a camera
underneath but similar to the other
other scenario you can use any type of
technology actually to do it but the
idea was you know if I have a tract
mobile device that has this actually
this amazingly high res display that's
even at this in this configuration this
was like a qvga phone so pretty you
proved laugh at this like in 2014 but
compared to that real projected imagery
I think it's probably SVGA it's still
within that little viewport is it was
about 11 or 12 times the pixel density
so think about this qvga and then you
take one of these like 4k 5 inch
displays on it now so and this is kind
of like a comment on you know how we
scale things and what we do with with
the pixels the way the way deliver into
the environment so with pretty much any
projector they are scaling very slowly
due to like the constraints of that that
particular technology you basically for
a large reasonably large image it takes
this basically more dollars than working
within the constraints of a few inches
but it's not only about like the pixel
density obviously so
about I mean if you look at this image
the rear projection is now the lysis are
like off in this lab but it would
obviously be issues with ambient light
contrast all these all these things that
just the LCD on that display doesn't
have to deal with another things that
are happening here so this is yes just
give you a context so this is like a
slice from a CT scan and we're looking
basically exploring different parts of
it in this viewport so both getting the
benefit of the resolution and the
contrast and brightness but also able to
switch between different phases of the
exams this essentially word the contrast
fluid is in different parts of off the
body
yeah so I guess the proximity would
would be an issue right so I mean as
soon as you project something the
further away the larger image this is
really trying to take into account that
you have you have like a large space for
context and then you have like a small
area for focus but you could imagine if
you're doing things a some sort of some
height that you're sort of masking
because you don't want the whole image
to move around so you're masking what
you're actually what you can sort of fit
inside so but i would say i mean if
you're interested in in handheld project
projectors like Chang cows work a
University of Toronto is not MSR was
really nice and he did like a very very
extensive exploration of that space and
what you can do with sort of handheld
projectors that are tracked and that you
can sort of manipulate content with ya
any other questions so also mention that
like last couple years we've been trying
to also explore more well you know what
we can do if we could actually move
these pixels not just as color changes
on a screen but or in the environment
and I think that's a second big big
limitation of all these others the
system that I've shown so far but I was
like really fortunate to start
collaborating with with Sean Danielle
and Hiroshi in the media lab and we have
a number of different papers in this
space where we're looking at sort of the
you know what is the sweet spot between
being able to prototype dynamic physical
surfaces mixing that with augmented
reality both in like mapping graphics
directed to like a surface topology but
also doing things in the in the space
and going in between representations in
various ways so so just as we can
control pixels on the screen and your
interactions by
I mean take any most software where
you're manipulating something there's a
constraints you snap two things you
align stuff so the question with like
the our first paper around in form was
what if we try to bring similar
capabilities to the physical world so if
you want to touch an object in the world
why can it become larger or if you want
to move something along a straight line
why can't you why can't you create the
grooves to guide your physical
interaction just collect similar to this
this ball if I want to move this on a
straight line it's hard but if i do it
like along the edge of the laptop it
takes almost no cognitive effort so this
is a lot about guiding like facilitating
your interaction but also restricting
them through these constraints and
another aspect of this is also
manipulating objects so we were with
this display it's like a two and a half
the shape display with 30 by 30 30 by 30
pins crazy engineering effort that the
Sean and Daniel add but the limitations
are of course that you can only actually
things up and down and then you can
simulate movement through through
animations but that's why we kind of
like bring in physical objects because
that allows us to sort of break the
limits or like that the constraints of
this physical volume and its degrees of
freedom so this an example of so like a
physical 3d viewers you're able to pick
a model and then go into an editing mode
and notice that every time you do
something just as a menu would pop up in
there on your screen we adapt the
physical space to inform you and guide
you of what you're able to do and which
you're not able to do based on the
specific mode and like here you know the
question is also you know how do you how
do you interact in free space and
combine that with a system like this so
so these are like some initial ideas
around tools bringing them into these
devices
no I don't know if you're familiar with
the marble answering machine is a
classical cannibal you I concept no okay
yes so this was this was an idea about
you know taking information and making
it physical and being able to manipulate
that information and understand that you
know one message for missed call can
actually there's something about the
quality of knowing that this is a
message and I can do things with that
message and it was like a proposal from
from you know a while back and what they
implemented here is sort of cat the new
dynamic version of this marble answering
machine I'm not playing the audio but
what we're seeing is essentially this
message and how that message can be both
mini played by the users so pick picks
it up and all right actually skip back a
little bit as you fast okay the suspense
okay so what we're seeing here is that
as you have like a missed call a model
pops up and it's sort of sits there
waiting for the user to basically you
have both the embodiment of the message
and its location in physical space we
have two messages they're using come up
and pick up pick one up put them in the
playback spot or slot and as it starts
playing is also moving us to show you
like sort of where it is in the track
and by moving it backwards you sort of
like have a way to to rewind it and when
it's done its moves over to the sort of
like completed and then you can discard
it by putting it on the top so just like
I think like a pretty interesting
example that that ties together a lot of
ideas from from tangible user interfaces
but in this space of the NAM
call shape this place so now I would
like to take a little as a small small
segue to talk about you know how this
also can fit outside of the strictly
academic community I mean this other
projects that I show though I use very
expensive equipment the fragile
technology that you know you only keep
in a little lab setting and maybe only
run for like half an hour so what I was
doing my PhD I was also interested in
seeing how this could sort of like same
ideas could be implemented in more
physical spaces i had this small agency
where we worked with museums and events
means the custom interactive surfaces
and installations and so on the last
thing actually did before coming to
Google was I was back in Sweden we put
together a proposal together with Alba
fast Lenore architects for a new science
center and in Stockholm so we were
working on so the cost of development
and I was kinda like tech curating the
experiences for this so it's a pretty
wild space there is producing it right
now so we'll see how how much of this
will actually actually happen but it's
the theme on the on the creative brain
it's like different stages stuff I'm is
very fitting two different stages of
your perception and experiences you
start by actually coming into this room
that represents like the synapses in the
brain and essentially yeah but here if
you visit Stockholm sometime end of next
year you might have a chance to go and
visit it but I wanted to show another
project that's a little bit more smaller
in scope she also worked with a
children's science museum just outside
of Stockholm together with a good friend
of mine I've been Coulson is like
completely absolutely amazing
electromechanical artist so you usually
met at the intersection of select
software electronics electronics
mechatronics and this was commissioned
piece to create some sort of interactive
thermometer for outdoor use that I
wanted in the municipality so d'italia
so what we built for this was this arrow
that points to the degrees in Celsius
and as temporal changes moves up and
down unfortunate i don't have a time
lapse of this so I mean doesn't move
that much in any of the video so you can
really tell but my my goal since last
for the last three years has been to go
there and set up a camera for you know I
could sit there for two months and pour
this was also to crowdsource so content
from the public so the public were they
were able to send in their favorite
right whether saying so you know it's
raining cats and dogs as crazy hot or
whatever and these these weather sayings
were mapped to based on the season and
conditions humidity temperature and so
on so here's just like some examples
from just after we installed it so it's
so it's like a pretty minimal display
just the scrolls by these expressions
very slowly and thing was seven or eight
different languages that are sort of
represented in or like my like a large
amount of people are speaking around
here and it was I think it's very
related to this idea of you know the
context sets the stage and doesn't need
to happen that much you have a very
limited think it was 128 x 64 LED
display like I'm in a huge LED display
but the stage is set by dash embodiment
of this era where it's placed and
so the content inside of it
be interesting time ups actually when
with all the text was the vehicle yeah
so so the weather conditions are all of
them are classified based on the season
so if it's summer and it's raining then
you might pick something like the
raining cats and dogs is raining a lot
in the summer but if it's if it's like
the typical thing for the season maybe
we wouldn't use it and it's just I think
it's about 400 of these these sayings
that it's like fat in based on what we
can sense with on the roof of that that
installation okay no so well they should
be saying this but we were actually
thinking about like a night mode so we I
mean I did official night mode they were
just like kick in you know it's like 4am
I'll just give you something else for
like two hours we're either either
interactive or just yeah I don't know
players and gif animations or something
but yeah coming back to our friend the
doctor I think so without giving away
too much I mean it's sci-fi from the 60s
should still see it but without giving
away too much I mean this doctor after a
while have this amazing capability but
it was not controllable so he was always
kind of liked seeing this this this this
x.x review and even if it's you know
kind of funny to talk about this in the
context of sci-fi I think it's sort of
ties into a lot of what our computer
systems are doing we're not necessarily
adjusting the context we are not
necessarily giving the user control of
what they're experiencing and that is
you know the difference between
something that is truly augmenting your
reality versus taking over your reality
and I mean it's a lot of things that are
sort of bubbling right now and both in
in the bay area but also more globally
in terms of like interfaces that have a
both the potential and a risk of
changing our perception in an
uncontrollable way so what I'm saying is
that you know if if you're relevant if
you know a lot about the user and the
context and what they're doing you
probably don't need to add too much and
that's what I think that you're is more
about augmenting reality while
preserving realism rather than
distracting you from reality and
breaking realism so with all these
examples you know with the Astor that's
just adding very little rendering I mean
I didn't comment on that but I was very
interested in in computer graphics in
the beginning but I was like the first
project where I'm like wow what if I
could render as little little as
possible and you should read adjust a
few like very simple geometry of these
like force results and the real world
will fill it in and it also means that
the real world that I'm experiencing
with extreme fidelity and extreme
quality will actually bridge like the
reduced capability of that display so
the just like a benefit and in tying
into that and I think it's you know
something similar with our immaterial
displays in terms of bringing those
pixels into the world and using that as
a backdrop one comment on these like the
light sense system I think is I always
think in in terms of like seamlessness
and ways in which we can add these add
these augmentations without creating
creating something that's that's drawing
but I think that you can also exploit
that to your benefit so wit with light
sense like the edge
the display and it's like it's a little
displaced it's actually not perfectly it
wasn't actually even tracked the
rotation wasn't tracked because I add
these Java ME phones we couldn't do any
like great graphics so like just
retaining an image would have just
killed it so but I mean the fact that
there were seams and allowed my senses
to fill in so if there were no seems
they look like they've gone edge to edge
and you would have clearly seen that
misalignment I think that would have
been more problematic so thats also
something to keep in mind that
seamlessness does not always mean that
the visuals you know should be sugar
overlaid in like the most perfect sense
and I mean within form obviously that's
like taking the step that big step
forward but also limiting in in terms of
like the resolution of this displays
just 30 by 30 pixels and and some height
but through context by its adapting to
what you're doing through visuals that
are projecting onto onto the surface
again we're able to fill in and we're
able to sort of understand what's
happening without resorting to like some
separate system but I think what's
missing across all of these and that's
something that I'm really really excited
about and I think that we have huge
potential to explore further now is how
all these all these technologies affect
our human to human interactions this is
all interacting with some sort of
information I'm manipulating something
in in the computer and the computer is
giving me feedback and guiding me or
helping me or restricting me so our most
recent the with paper was on physical
telepresence so about sheep capture and
display and trying to embody remote
collaborators and remote objects and
allowing us to capture the shape and
display it and and basically use that as
an actuator
I'll show you sure Sean is going to be
talking a lot more about this in spring
I think he's giving a maybe not here but
giving a talk on campus i'm not going to
go into too much detail but i'll show
you like a quick preview and just touch
on some aspects of this but essentially
it's about linking two systems and using
the ability to capture the shape and
transmit it to control objects and
creating a presence that are on the
other side without being there but still
providing there for instance over there
and this is like a like a toot sped up
video into the interest of time so just
like a little teaser but the point stood
that just want to highlight quickly is
what you're seeing here is you know a
participant on the right hand side that
is has placed this big yellow Lego block
that is now so replicated on the left
hand side flutter participant and vice
versa with another block and the ability
to do this in real time means that you
now can start playing around with
representation and embodiment and mix
and match between physical objects and
shape rendering so for example here so
we're seeing here we have a get this
real hand with this real ball and then
transmitted it's like a virtual rendered
or physically rendered hand and physical
rendered ball what we've seen here is
the physical rendered hand but it's
actually controlling a linked object on
the other side so to create the illusion
that you know the hand is actually
manipulating this this thing other
aspects that I find really fascinating
and it is very related to robotic
surgery and and Teller surgery is the
idea to use the computer as a mediator
of your capabilities so this is going
wave
beyond that that sci-fi movie was only
about the visuals but this is actually
about what I can do in motor space so as
soon as you're going through a computer
it doesn't mean that everything should
be worse you can actually export that so
for telus surgery and robotic surgery I
mean you guys have like this amazing
charm lab with that are looking at all
these things but yeah so like a
different different Hardware setups what
idea is that you know if I'm controlling
like surgical robotics with epoxy why
can I remove my tremor why can't I scale
down my motion to get more precision and
so on or you know adding some
constraints and like the workspace so
that I can't like you know just swing
out of other thing so we were interested
in applying those ideas and try to take
them all a bit further but in a rather
than controlling just like a single
actually end effector or multiple end
effectors it's more about now surface
topology so what were you was was very
quickly flashing through a video was
ideas of transformation so maybe I want
to have a bigger hand so it's not only
about my motion by might want to have a
bigger hand remotely I want to rotate it
into some some position that's more
convenient you also saw that I did when
I'm represented remotely I don't need to
be have a one-to-one mapping between the
shape of my hand or my limbs I can
replace that with anything really if I
can track it so here we are just
switching to different tools so this is
like a sort of cloth that's easier to
grab grab a ball for example and what
you're also seeing back here is that we
don't need to shape around er everything
when we don't need to be be consistent
right so we've switched off the the arm
it's just like rendered with graphics
the rest that actually need to
manipulate something is rendered with
with shape
and you don't need to be it's not just
about having one thing over there you
can control multiple things so here it's
a little hard to see but essentially
this is a copy of the hand that's
helding up holding up this this board
and then it's frozen in space and this
user is now moving across and using the
other still two free hands to point and
interact with with users as essentially
replicating and leaving copies of
yourself if that's something you want to
do and a little bit from from the
in-form video you saw like there's this
constraints in these surfaces so in
terms of given that the pins are moving
up and down just vertically you can't
like you really move things over like to
drastically so here here's like a tool
that's basically use a brush to indicate
that it's like a lateral movement that
it's about to happen and that sort of
translates into this animation of these
prints in other ways of doing this where
you may want to interact indirectly
through tracking the hand above the
space but I highly recommend you guys to
see Sean former stalk I think I think
he's giving one on campus in the spring
and he'll talk much more much more depth
about shape this place and all the
challenges and opportunities in there
but I think that this is an amazing
area-specific bothh both of you think
with the shape output and shape capture
but also thinking about that from from
regular visual visual sense and audio
what happens actually when we start to
modify our capabilities and our
representation over a distance through
the computer so a few select closing
points I think that seamlessness is
extremely important and I think that's
what is the distinction between
something that is just alien technology
that's introduced an
injected into your space and your
experience versus something that's
really giving you a slight augmentation
of your ality and perception and
relevancy is is also maybe even more
important the key because like I said
the more relevant we are of where we're
placing things and how we're showing
things the less do we need to introduce
so we can stick with using the reality
as a backdrop and just inject whatever
we need at whatever that location is so
if its navigation maybe I just need one
pixel to show me where my next meeting
is rather than having a map to that I
need to dive into but that pixel needs
to be locked in space and be relevant
and this point is pretty obvious and I
guess especially to this class but I
mean you also want all of this to be
interactive we're not doing things
offline but we are connecting displays
and sensing interaction to sort of like
a unifying principle here so I didn't
talk about some of my other work but I'm
also very interested in applying some of
these techniques specifically to
problems in HCI in in medicine and
health so you can find plenty of
projects also on this on my website so
yeah thanks a lot for joining me in this
little little journey through reality
and happy to take some more questions
the floor is open sure so the vast
majority of the work you talk just on
the displayed side you talk about them
I'm thinking if you or colleagues on
working on the project making on with
what they've been doing in the half day
side of this whole equation of trying to
get on for example or tactile feedback
in the certain situations of I mean like
especially that wore this on screen I'd
kind of battle via the pc case for
trying to figure out like these Mario
response for a half as well yeah that's
a great question I mean is that
something that is true for all augmented
reality it's usually very focused on on
the visual sense but yeah there's
nothing that doesn't say that you could
I what's a interfere but enhance which
will modify your perception through any
of the other senses or capabilities so
when it comes to tactile I think that I
should this work with around the shape
this place is a pretty good example
because that's actually giving you all
the time not only synthesized haptic
feedback but you're actually getting
real real physical affordances which
gives you that passive feedback but
display like that could also be used to
you know to more modulate things and say
that you wanted to generate friction or
something in terms of the fog screen and
the material displays I believe that
some people have looked at more like
string-based haptics like as a device
called spider which has
essentially actuated strings that you
attach to some some basically hold on to
do something with and they will pull in
different ways what based on the content
and because that's like one of the
things with it with the Fox string you
have like a large area so it doesn't
work with like a small haptic device but
having something more like full body I
think that it's that still comes down to
this yeah kind of undesirable
instrumentation in that you're not not
only instrumented you actually
physically linked to to a ceiling or a
wall the last thing I could say about
this though is oh yeah so we did it we
have the one project at the media lab or
we looked at motion guidance the one at
the lower right and the idea that
basically also this person to the right
is wearing um bring a suit as a motion
capture suit so we know the position of
the limbs and the body in space but it's
also wearing a pneumatic vest it has
fountain bag is one of these like gaming
thus like when you play games you get
like shots in different locations but we
repurposed it for like education and
more better better better use cases and
he's also has it also has some Bluetooth
connected vibrotactile actuators on some
parts of the body and what this was this
was an exploration in how you could give
motion guidance if you're trying to
learn tai chi or yoga or tennis you can
get a little bit based on some model of
what the perfect motion is or what it
should be or a sequence that you try to
follow this was like a way to map your
body in the space and give you graceful
feedback to sort of guide you into that
right motion so it's not just telling
you
you know go like this it was trying to
take into also take into your
trajectories and your current motion to
sort of gracefully get you there without
being being a drawing so yeah so I think
it's like very interesting area so you
need to comment in a telepresence
collaboration about changing modifying
capabilities or representations across
distances he say any more about thought
you had a lazy would change how I kind
of render myself above me in traffic
people with yeah I can talk about our
life I mean any specific aspect of it
maybe just curious about directions you
were exploring there or what what new
affordances our capabilities i can
capable people right i want to tell you
about something that we did not explore
to think your other aspect of this is is
this is all shape and location and
motion and how you replicate that over a
distance so it's so we're breaking the
one to one mapping in in geometry but
what if you also started to break that
in terms of time okay so say that i want
to learn how to play the piano and i
have access to this amazing piano
teacher and maybe she's she has two
thousand students that are participating
at the same time oh but I and I want to
I want to do with in real time for
various reasons so some point I'm like
oh I want to just slow down on that
piece you know just to get like that the
tactile feedback of feeling the keys but
I need I want to do it in my pace
because I can't do it that fast but I
need I mean at that point once you've
broken the like the synchronous link how
do you then sort of ketchup or correct
for that so you just jump into the
future or like the sorry into the
present because you dwelled in the past
or do you like ramp up in in some ala
elegant way
I think that's you know there's like a
lot of potential in there and you can
think about not only doing this on a
time scale maybe I just want to boost
the actuation to feel the keys more as
she's like pressing on a key exaggerated
yeah so there's this essentially comes
down to what's what are the transfer
functions that would be useful when you
are communicating with someone over a
distance and does it happen globally we
also think about it in a more local
sense so we say that I remove to
participate in yeah in this lecture and
I'm seeing all you guys and I still want
to have like this whole real time
experience but now i just wanted to slow
down one of the people here it's like
see okay for whatever reason maybe it
maybe I mean I it's always easy to refer
to more like a medical center or
something but yes a or like a traffic
accidents you see the whole sea and cars
you like oh let me rewind just this one
object all right and then let me
continue playing so I think it's like a
interesting space that has like a lot of
room for for HCI techniques
others Panthers strike sure so would you
think it would be possible to simulate
actual physical presence in the sense
that like shaking hands or hugging or
those sorts of interpersonal
interactions with the sort of system you
know anything yeah so that's a great
question as well so there's another
another version of the system that's
called transform that was it is also in
in that I mean I strongly recommend of
course you guys to read that paper
physical telepresence from wisc this
year we won that one aspect in the paper
is you know how do you how do you
connect things that are sort of remotely
synchronized so if I wanted to feel your
touch should you it go like this and you
kind of like feeling pushing into its
pops up or are we am I doing this that
you feel like the attempt and it's just
basically is more like about pin screen
sort of membrane were you feeling me on
the other side or or like you pulled
into him into the display but it's been
it actually goes back to hero she had
like a some work quite some time ago
which was called in touch and come touch
it was like these rollers that were
connected a very elegant system
essentially basically no computer in
between so just like mechanically and
electrically connected so as you would
roll term the three rollers the three
wooden rollers also very likely nice
design so she would roll this I would
feel this on other side this is just an
amazing given given the bandwidth and
the limitation just like that its design
with such much care actually makes it
like really compelling to feel another
person and and just like you know three
rollers but
there's so much there's so many
parameters that are going across that
wire in terms of like speed and
acceleration and so on so so yes and I
think you know as you go to something
that's more has more dimensions I mean
that has like three degrees of freedom
yeah you can do more the question is
what and how you do it in a in a way
that's not scary or alien 18 because
it's still I mean especially in this
case it's still like a grid of pins that
are moving up and down that's why I
think that yeah maybe i should say this
as well i mean one one important aspect
or perspective on the on the all these
like all this shape display work is that
it's actually not we're not envisioning
these particular this particular device
to be the ultimate device because you
can break out like a few maybe you know
if you're doing something that maybe
only requires those three rollers we can
prototype this on this test bed yes that
gives you like an environment to explore
in a sort of medium to low fidelity way
what it could be like but for any real
system I think there's like a lot of
care needs to go into actually
interfacing physically with a human so I
don't know if it was wood or bamboo and
metal it looks great it felt great you
know this is different